that's super creepy oh
God
no got hey going BR my name isie welcome
to Pony Island it's a lovely little game
look at that pony corn thing did I say
Pony corn it looked like a
Triceratops those don't exist anymore uh
it's a lovely nice game some says for
kids I say [__] that you know if I want
to col her a coloring book and I'm a
full grown man I can do it if I want to
and same goes for this game I really
just want to have a relaxing nice little
afternoon where nothing bad
H where did all the collar
go uhhuh what is what am I looking at
this this this the eye of an hor pony
Island no I I prefer the other uh the
other intro with TR catops but I
guess okay I guess we can't start the
game
I what the [__] is
[Music]
this let me play you damn
it uh options have cheerful
[Music]
facade it's stuck on Pony physics no I
want Pony physics
definitely uh free tick
a free ticket oh what is
this no it still doesn't
Advanced
range there must could this in that
purchases
no take away the Obscure
options what the [__] is this game
fix what
uh than there we
go oh man what a [__] weird game okay
start
please there we
go start the thank you finally we can
enjoy a nice relaxing game about ponies
I'm wearing a pony shirt today I didn't
even think about that I mean of course I
it's nice isn't it I love ponies ponies
are my favorite what the [__] is this
let me play the damn game go
away Jesus
Christ it's a long loading SC oh you
just had to fix it didn't
you I want to play the game yeah it was
going to work I tested it a thousand
times it's almost time to
Play
Welcome to Pony Island finally I love
ponies so much Ponies are my favorite
yes oh I can head
Bob break it
oh a [__] I hit it all right let's do
this better you're my friend he needs a
name uh ponycorn that's his name awesome
job PS creativity you really nailed
it
I like the music it's [__]
nice um it's not as relaxing as I hoped
for but uh maybe that's something for
the later stages there
we did I huge success I did it level oh
my God I'm leveling up like
crazy this is
amazing think we broke the game continue
[Music]
go Pony
Kar
yay I love you this is like one of those
Happy Wheels level where you have to
jump over with POG man but
better this uh game really makes me
reflect on on
horses and
unicorns do I what the [__] is this 360
no
horse
impossible
skill you heard it here first PR should
we continue I don't okay experience the
rest of pony Island insert your soul to
continue my
soul I sold that years ago what the [__]
am I going to do oh here we
go pay CH all right soul required how do
I put my soul into this game
uh all right let's try
here oh so it goes
here uh and then crash game oh [__] no
no no no no no no no no no oh god oh uh
oh uh we're
fine how do I insert my
soul oh here we go
okay Pony galaxy. XE Pony Island I sure
love that I have a lot of corrupted
files here walk through code block swap
the loop
code continue code once a game what wait
what once the game has crashed twice
close the two windows there an actual
walk
through Pony Galaxy my
favorite I love Pony Galaxy it's my
favorite game Let's uh put it down for
now uh oh
no
[Music]
messenger hopeless Soul what was that
hello hello can you see this now hello
hello
hi my prayers are answered hello how are
you I is a me my
piepie is it hello is a me
pie I have been traveling in this
machine for a very long time I do not
want you to iic but it is possible that
we that we may share the same fate I
have planned but I do not know how to
means to execute it you must help me I
is a me PewDiePie will you help me uh
[Music]
absolutely oh was that yes
yes oh God what is
that oh we got another one hello again
uh
hi you must feel good about yourself you
hacked your way out of pony what the
positive feedback look for completing
Monday jumping task wasn't engaging
enough for
you it was so that you had to escape you
just had to where did you go oh I'm here
what the [__] is going
on do not speak to
him now my plan there are three core
program files that his entire operating
system depends on
deleting a single one will lessen the
power that he wields but we must delete
all three to truly Escape do you uh yes
oh God who are no oh my mom my
mom you are so arrogant I have been
making changes to Pony Island we will
see what you think of it this
time oh ah
ah enough of that you are mine now say
yes matter okay so we need to delete the
files which one are there the core
files I am going to go missing isn't
that a creepy
pasta no [__] what I can't typing
something
else what the [__] no I can't click away
ah
no damn it oh god what the
[__] don't no I want to play Pony
Island what the [__] is this
game oh
God improved loading times oh excellent
you thought it was too easy oh God what
do you think no I have a re how do I
block
these what I keep
respawning stop respawning
me game over
no
the my G is challenging much fair come
back when your skills
improved Advanced options could that be
it ooh that could be it here we
go Advanced Audio what the hell what
Mortal heartbeat what the hell is
this struggling
Hardware can we turn down the ominous
[Music]
humming what the [__]
is
ah
old prototype options Free
Will Pony mobile man the old options
were way better really useless options
there are better options than this Pony
salvation there it is no no no we need
the pony laser no
no we got it get the pony
laser I don't know how to hack you
[__] that's right increase size no come
on
ah you're starting to piss me
off oh you got to go
no
no the
[__] we got to hack we got to hack it
again okay there we
go come
on I got you
[__] I want that pony
laser we will have the pony laser oh I
see it that's the last okay oh God this
is a little more complicated where is it
increased size we got to
go I don't
know
[Music]
left yeah Pony
lace
fa oh oh oh oh oh my
God go back in and turn that off you
can't play with that [__] you we're
going to play with the pony ler
[__]
yeah okay I forgot to
jump take
this take
this
yeah Pony
laser
woohoo that's what I'm talking about
when I talk about Pony lasers
[__] oh God this is actually a little
difficult come on I can't fail now come
on Pony lasers that's right Pony lasers
that's right Pony laser [__] that's my
pony lasers yeah oh oh oh oh oh Pony
lasers [__] what oh it keeps going okay
no problem our Pony lasers all day our
Pony laser all day long hold not long
[__] I think that was a sentence there
somewhere I'm way too excited this is so
exciting this game I have no idea what's
going to
happen how do I get those oh yeah well I
that should have been obvious okay so
you collect like 24 secrets in the game
that's kind of cool we got three so far
I know I missed one but maybe we come
back I don't know we'll
see really unique game I love it I mean
I played other hacking game before but
this is
like I don't know
you cheater
cheat no pony corn what the
[Music]
[__] did we break the
game oh I made it in it seems he is
distracted this is our
chance okay all right we got to we got
to delete the files correct delete core
file this is it this is the core file
that looks like a demon over there it's
uh kind of defense that he set up to
guard the file shouldn't be a problem
since it's locked up
strange I don't like
[Music]
this what oh god what did I do I just
double clicked on it uh-oh
oh
god
[Music]
[__] did you believe this would be easy
yes that's what he
said uh what do I
do oh God all right we can do this we
can do this this is a
puzzle oh you
[Music]
dick there we go that's right [__] you
have luck on your side no ain't no luck
it's pure genius [__] but I am the
greater M all right we'll see about that
man we'll see about that
um there we go
oh God and we need a down arrow don't
we we need a down arrow
there I think we did
it I think we did it
woohoo yeah all right what are you doing
uh kicking your ass [__] I will not
fail my master oh god he has a master
all right [__] you then uh we need to go
there all right fair enough let's put
you
there okay I can put them there too okay
I got it I got I got this now we
[Music]
put
here we go there we go I don't know how
I'm so stupid there we
[Music]
go boom [__]
fool your prophit is false well I'm
still going to delete your no stop did I
do it I did
it sayon
[__] oh [__]
[__] [__]
[Music]
[__] did we do it can I go home now Mom
is that a dead pixel there is it my
screen or the game
I a [__]
sake that's we'll
proceed what is going
on hopefully
soul I don't guest hi girl all right so
we're in as a guest now triangle.png
[Music]
messenger and we can't talk to him well
there's always time to play Pony
Galaxy
yeah who's writing
me please respond when you find uh what
up
good it's good to see you that Asal guy
was mad false prophet he said I got to
wish that guy would stop still
there I'm playing pony [__] Galaxy
[__] oh God
yes you did well thank you however we
still have to deal with the other okay
fine but I really got a good high SCH
over damn it it won't be an easy it
won't be as easy for me to open another
portal I have an idea log into my user
profile the password is 2734 wow he just
gave it to me what a [__] idiot
[Music]
2734 okay we're in you made it I did now
what do we do now welcome to my home
he's never guessed my password thus
far anyways my plan open the search PRS
Tool uh
okay
ah there we go I fixed
it something less than 5% could allow me
to open another core
file oh I did
it Pony island. XE if you want to be
free of this machine you must delve into
Poland Pony Island once more I don't EnV
you but it must be done find Pony Island
play it as soon as I am able I will open
a portal for you the corruptor file
profile next to mine may be worth
investigating oh what
happened I what I made it
in ponies ponies oh here's all the
password wait his password is
ponies oh welcome back oh man we are
going back in Pony Island baby we're
going back in you got to dig
deeper my favorite game Pony
Island
sat great name great great just
fantastic oh God here we
go oh Adventure Mode
now you have been
busy so have oh God I have made some
changes to Pony
Island
okay I never cheat I don't know what
he's talking about we we didn't cheat a
thing oh God he's like you got to be
kidding me
what do these do are these portals
maybe
yep
uh oh God I can't move uh what happened
did the game actually [__]
up there you
go nail that
[__] fix pointer okay we're going in
baby hey
this is new there is a huge amount of
corrupted data north of you our best
chance at opening another portal lies
there just play along and don't let oh
God what is
that oh that's
awesome let's go bro start that [__] oh
God we got got to do this again oh no I
don't have the pony laser oh
what we got to hack the laser we got to
hack the pony
[Music]
laser that does not help
us oh I know how oh I know this that's
smart so now we charge up the
laser what laser power should we give it
let's give it
10 there we
go our laser power is
chin I don't think it makes any
difference but we did the puzzle thing
yeah woo that try Pony [__] that dry
Pony [__] oh
yes love the music it's [__]
awesome take this uh demons
I oh God it would be good if I knew how
to play Jesus
Christ let me just focus and I can do
this easy don't worry about it all right
got them all no problem I don't know why
it got me in this creepy ass Forest
anyway halfway there baby just got to
make sure I don't forget how to
jump actually the probably isn't jumping
the're proba is jumping oh God sorry
Satan don't point at me Satan oh he
shoots at me I didn't see it cuz I was
shooting him damn it there you
[Music]
jump yeah we got him okay there we go
woo that level is a little
tricky try leveling up
first you can grind for exp over over
here what the [__] okay well he said it
let's get some
[Music]
exp come on almost there we don't have
to die now all right we got exp come on
how much did we
gain are you [__]
kidding [__] you [__] you
Next Level Pony Wings shouldn't take too
long at this
rate oh we're going to hack this
[__] oh it's the same same type of
puzzle isn't it we'll just keep keep
leveling
up there it
is
W yeah in your face [__] why can't you
play my game the way I
intended enjoy the wings thank you
cheetah that's my wings [__] I don't
know how we used them but we [__] got
wings
now
yeah awesome fly on the wings of
pony fly Pony fly [__] yeah to the but
Hills Cave of truths what where do we
have you have done well to find this
what enter back to leave this place or I
may show you a vision uh Vision
please a
glimpse what the [__] oh god what the
[__] is
this ah
oh who was I when did I die who killed
me uh you were Jesus Pony
Jesus Pony Jesus
oh who was
I Theodore you left you left behind a
mother and a daughter I love
[Music]
balls you're doing so
great now I need time to create more
content for you why don't you take break
all right seems
fair uh
yes it actually quits the
game what the
[__] now come
back what the
[Music]
[__] the
what okay let's continue Pony Island I
[Music]
suppose so X needs to be under zero and
Y needs to be under zero another
puzzle well I suppose we can do
that so X needs to be zero and Y needs
to be positive so there we go that's
done then we're going to Loop the Y
where the [__] is the
Y and now we make it teleport over here
and then that's the pule done thank you
thank you very much everyone nail that
[__]
no okay uh we're going here now to this
Titanic keep my oh that looks
lovely I told you to take take a
break I need more time here you're not
ready for the boss
fight let me just code up so come on
level ah oops just a typo hold
on is a snowman again
more
[Music]
content create more ponies more friendly
content yes oh we're back here what the
[__] oh God another puzzle okay uh set
what do we need is oh it needs to be
over 900
okay oh I thought I did it last time but
okay well I did it now where do we go
now need build speed X10 okay
awesome oh new mascot hi there you're a
great
mascot slow down I don't know where to
go oh God all right oh we went in here
now okay okie
do you made it the final level of
Adventure Mode oh boy I sure love
Adventure
Mode I wanted to have more of a
buildup but you're here so we might as
well all right let's do
this the final boss is me of
course I can't tell if I'm doing damage
on what the [__] don't smiley face
me
[Music]
oh I still got to
play what the
[__] oh
[Music]
God this is
awesome oh
no how do I okay I got a shoot those
It's Tricky man I don't want to [__] up
now come
[Music]
on oh we got his [__]
jaw that's
disgusting oh I saw
too oh [__] we did it what oh uh okay uh
awesome can I have my soul
back delete the Cor damn it I can't
move you are being led astray can't you
see that destroying these FS will
prevent you from playing pony island
adventure but destroying the file is the
only way to advance the
plot what are
you get ready oh [__] what the
[__] all right we're deleting
[Music]
it
what
what gash did I fart did engar fart what
did you do
[Music]
engar oh wonderful
music ah finally the game I wanted to
play
today
[Music]
okay
uh-huh okay we were at an arcade and we
we had passed
out and we're
back this game we have one more core
file we have one more core file we play
this much we might as well finish it
that's how I feel like howy friend my
name's
lovey I love this guy
[Music]
okay hell
yeah oh
finally
[Music]
yeah okay let's play it
again I like this this version a lot
better I'm not going to
lie it's really cool later in the game
you get Pony wings and pony lasers it's
awesome
woo oh we got the pony wind of course
the the gust of air look at him blow
look at him
go
yay
butterflies Sho Sho shoot butterflies
tickle tickle
[Music]
oh my God I don't know what to say I'm
speechless
um there there we did
it wee oh Pony
Wings getting a little ahead of yourself
are
we you didn't even let me
explain
ah it's
okay oh man [__]
hell this game is breaking the fourth
wall so much I don't even know it's
[__]
awesome it's [__]
brilliant I really I said this before
and I'll say it again like in horror
games everyone does the same [__] and I
don't really feel like horror can be
something creative and I think this is a
great testimony to
that um I don't
[Music]
know
huh um there's some more what you
win looks like it's uh time for
uh puzzle
[Music]
break oh we we've got ourselves
a
pule all right this is a tricky one
ain't
[Music]
it sad little butterfly there you
go oh there's more I love the music
those purple signs are
tricky so
tricky is this it oh
[Music]
okay there we go all
right you might need
this what is
this oh
[Music]
what split universe what is
this there we go
it's [__] weird weird as [__]
[Music]
man there we go that was a little
tricky
wow you're really
smart it's all about the
ponies oh
God what do we got now
oh God no no no no no no no not that
again a not that
again what the hell are
those okay don't touch him got
it those we shoot shush butterflies
shush shush butterflies shush shush
away okay there you go you're
away no won't touch you there we go did
it now
that premium mode Place forehead to
screen to release Soul or
continue let's do or continue in filthy
peasant
mode no not Jesus or God uh what the oh
God oh God oh oh
God this makes it a lot trickier to
[Music]
kill you killed who what did a Tex say
what the [__] did a Tex say
no no no
no what the hell
man that ain't Fair
oh God these are
[Music]
shush come on
yes damn that was [__]
tricky God damn that was
tricky I knew I could do it
obviously God damn that must have taken
me like 10 minutes oh God do I touch
them or not I
don't no that isn't no goddamn Jesus and
his star shooting
abilities why did the Bible not tell of
these stories sorry Jesus I feel
terrible I really do but the pony had to
do it he's just too
cute don't touch
them what what is going
out oh
you already beat the fun
[Music]
levels
um
oh
sh I killed
Louie no oh we're back to these
ones oh God I hate the split ones
they're really
difficult
all right so what is our goal to get it
to corrupt 25 uh
75 no we need to corrupt over
[Music]
what about
this well it is
over okay so now it's over 666 how do we
get it there oh no
oh maybe this will
work okay we did it I am not in for
another tricky
puzzle uh uh maybe the corrupted one huh
oh it
disappeared do you like
ponies what the
[__]
hello uh
331 331 years what you have slept for
centuries
what
what I have a truth to tell you what the
[__] you are not the only trap Soul
there are
thousands okay like you they did not
surrender to Lucifer and fall screaming
hell but they are stuck all the same
edar what do you he's stuck too perhaps
on a puzzle perhaps on a level you have
destroyed two of the three cor files if
you are still resolved I will help you
find the
third or devil Island what the
[__] no I don't want to in there you can
find
the pony island of old version of the
game that he created and then discarded
Pony Island 3D search through the
discarded
games find me a place where I can place
a portal to find uh there seems Pi Tex a
teex spased he made a tech space Pony
Island oh
God okay
Blackness a shimmer of light a BAL star
is EMB bazzle on the dusty screen system
Tech incorporate it says continue
yes oh an interactive menu appears two
beautiful ponies accompany the text Pony
Island the menu buttons hold such
promise start game says one options says
the other uh credits let's try
credits as the credits fly by you are
failed with all one name stands Out
Among the with the rest you return to
main menu with a new fund appreciation
for developers the menu buttons hold
such
promise okay uh
options a vast area of options are
displayed before you and cheerful facade
okay do I get to pick
them this is really
creepy
okay we did it we started the
game luckily it's a Well programmed
loading screen it loads very quickly
very quickly the game is loaded and you
are a pony a beautiful sunset over some
perfect Green Hills this almost as good
as the original you feel the Wind
Through Your Man as you Gallop across
the grassy Valley Hawk a wooden gate
approaches do you jump shoot or do
nothing I'll
jump you leap majestically over the gate
but another gate approaches what will we
do we'll we'll jump
again you cleared the gate and land
running
awesome but now an enemy approaches we
will
shoot Le is from your mouth fire at the
enemy obliterating it another gate
appears jump it looks like it might be a
little too far away do nothing
then you allow the gate to get
closer it looks jumpable now
jump do you I I thought I select the
jump
jump you feel smart for
waiting a tall shimmering flag approach
a person we do
nothing didn't
matter your neck breaks when it impacts
the flying post what the [__] it's okay
you are no longer that pony an explosion
of confetti announces your success you
gain 9 million experience and reach
level thousand Surrender Your Soul now
to Able Graphics I don't think I can
open a portal here damn it come
back ah we'll try another one
okay oh [__] me that scared
me let's do Pony all in
3D [__]
yeah
I don't know what's going to happen here
I really
don't uh start it's this oh it's three
oh
you oh my
God there's the
gate best game ever no that didn't wow
this is so much
fun how long do I keep doing this
does this go on
forever it looks like it goes on
forever I mean I can see the Horizon oh
never
mind okay it goes a little faster
now but I think we got
this let's not [__] up
now insert your soul now to upgrade to
40 okay that's that won't work
either but I want to I want to insert my
soul come
on okay we'll we'll keep trying there's
Pony Island mana and devil Island let Su
devil Island
last what is
meta no there going to be someone
commenting over Pony Island that'd be
pretty
meta that's going to I guess we'll try
devil
[Music]
Island this is a little too dark for me
Lucifer what the
[__] oh
god oh [__] me what the [__] is
this okay I guess we're guess we're
doing
[Music]
this this game is so [__]
weird are we shooting actual ponus this
time I don't I don't know how I feel
about
that ah [__] it life's handing you
lemons so squeeze them in your eye
that's that's what I always
say um getting very confused about
this sorry ponies you you must burn
there you go Bronies rate this game 10
out of
10 not enough sexual content um success
in your they keep wanting me to insert
my soul like I don't I don't know how to
do
that
um here we go let's keep let's keep
playing gosh gosh I'm getting a little
tired I'm not I'm not used to playing
this as
modius um I used to to playing
this as modius Please Release
Me I have reached you as
modius
[Music]
uhhuh fair enough
that's
it that's it
got
it say something
[Music]
disgusting say something
vile I didn't know I was logged
in what how the [__]
does
what oh god I
stopped this I'm not logged in what
that's so
creepy that's super creepy oh God
no ah I got
[__] damn that's
genus that really got me I was like how
the [__] did they I haven't spoken oh my
God oops I looked
away uh that phrase for me H Pony
[Music]
Jesus
[__]
okay I'm not looking away this
time that's so
creepy that's a genius
puzzle I really enjoy that
what
[Music]
nail
that it is
friendly
no I
didn't no what I didn't see
anything really I I'm I [__]
up
what I saw it now I saw it
now how is that
possible how could I not see that for
the longest
time look how many times I watched it 41
no wait 21 I really didn't look away
though
remember this
what finally my God I I
was type 666 okay I can do it
that actually type 777 [__] you
well stop Skyping me [__] whatever the
[__] Jesus
Christ actually type 777 [__]
you you have phenomenal ability to
follow instructions thank
you oh
God
what what
happened
what no don't [__] with me this
is
uh
H what
you to destroy this core file oh
really
okay
and now we delete that
[Music]
[__] okay we deleted them
all Victory question mark I don't think
[Music]
so oh
cool insert a recovery disc oh it's you
hey
okay I
[Music]
assume you don't know Fant fantastic I
don't even know if I can trust
you and Mara is calling
me hey girl for this purpose Little
Pony we may meet
again
yeah that's
true should I should I do it
[Music]
Pros are these people who got stuck at
the
puzzles
[Music]
wo [__]
yeah okay get all those corrupted
fils you don't want to give me your
souls
fine
you're no longer asking oh god what the
[__] is this that is a sexy
beast how do I dodge okay I can
jump go ponies
go that is a sexy [__] I wish I
had his peex oh I almost forgot
what an old friend wanted to say goodbye
uh okay no you killed me I'm sorry
[Applause]
we got him
yes thank
you oh they're taking his legs and [__]
that's
awesome missing
texture okay we're almost there 10 more
per come on
br oh God did we do it I don't
know oh I think we
did that was one hell of a [__]
Journey where are we going I don't
know oh man it's been three hours since
I started this
recording I did take some breaks but
Jesus Christ I did not expect that when
I started
this oh that's cute that's that's
adorable made it all worth
it Daniel mullers is see the only one
who made this game now we have consulted
designer and musician awesome and play
testers nice beat boxing to finish it
with so that was Pony Island I really
enjoy this game I gave it a lot of
Praise throughout me playing it so I
don't really see a pain on me going on
but I would really recommend this game
man uh
nice short game really worth playing
great job everyone involved in making it
I'm really glad I got to be able to play
it in front of you bros and I hope you
enjoyed it as well check it out if you
enjoyed it or recommend it to someone
else that's it for me for now and as
always stay awesome
[Music]
br oh God
what
no
uh please just hear me
out I once told you that we shared the
same fate but this is only partially
true your soul is your soul in the game
was afid when you beat it but mine will
be trapped for as long as Pony Islands
rut and bits sit on your hard
drive I have been carefully guiding you
from from the
beginning moving you towards this moment
knowing that if you did not complete the
game you may never uninstall
it so please do it delete Pony
island save my
soul and it
quits it just quits itself
um yeah we're g to delete the
game okay
um here we
go Pony
[Applause]
Island
deleted we did
it oh this is so
weird okay I'll see
[Music]
you